le temps des mécènes comme l'était
howard use a bien disparu dans le monde
du cinéma mais il y a un point commun
entre ce milliardaire mort dans le
mystère est un jeune comédien français
dont la carrière en quelques mois s'est
développé de façon fulgurante
je parlais de gérard depardieu je pense
que le point commun de leur caractère et
cette forme de violence interne avec
laquelle depardieu heurter bouscule
certains tabous de notre société
vedette de la dernière femme où le héros
écrase et par les difficultés du couple
se mutile avec un couteau électrique
voici gérard depardieu 26 ans numéro un
du peloton des acteurs les plus demandés
en 24 mois et 7 films il est passée de
l'obscurité au salaire à six chiffres
hiver au printemps dans sa maison de
banlieue ou dans les rues de saint
germain des prés il porte les mêmes
bottes les mêmes blouson la richesse et
la célébrité n'ont pas changé son
apparence
je vous ai pas dit un jour tiens je
viens de signer un très bon contrat j'ai
raté mon cadeau non je vais manger
j'ai mangé sentir lors les cadeaux je
sais pas
juste à temps des fois je vais faire une
voiture aujourd'hui la barbe en marché
du bois marchand vous n'avez jamais été
tenté par l'idée de vouloir yonne au
festival de cannes
si j'étais tenté aussi de ça mais ma
femme elle s'en fout complètement du
violeur on obtient une espèce d'inertie
puis on s'en fout où est ce que vous
vous êtes fait tatouer cette petite
étoile au service militaire
non vous me direz pourquoi parce que
j'étais réforme et je lis que ce soit
quelqu'un d'émotif pathologique sa salle
à manger bien ce qui est vraiment
l'homme des bois
de quel bois sortir de plus près sur la
sologne est réservé aux parents mon cas
est relié jamais choisi d'une enfant
l'hyperémotivité de ses 19 ans lui sert
maintenant dans ses rôles chirurgien
voyous ingénieurs il est toujours
convaincant vous affrontez la bretagne
pour faire quoi la voie pour je
travailler un peu sur les plages fait un
peu de tout plein djibril âgées qu'est
ce qui vous avait donné envie
devenir comédien savait pas très bien
j'avais envie d'un très fort de moi mais
je ne pouvais pas le dire
alors j'ai commencé par un mentir je
disais que j'étais acteur et puis à
force de le dire a des jambes c'est avec
le fasse puis je les fais ça corresponde
exactement avec ce que je pouvais avec
ma violence il est marié depuis sept ans
avec elizabeth
quand il ne tourne pas il joue avec son
fils et sa petite fille
je crois beaucoup à la famille je crois
en tout cas que dans la famille on peut
retrouver les joies de l'enfance les
attributs comment est ce que vous
arrivez à avoir une vie de famille et
vie professionnelle extrêmement remplie
jusqu'à présent j'ai essayé mais
maintenant je m'aperçois c'est très
difficile alors je vais être obligé
d'arrêter pour essayer de faire avec ma
tribu ce que j'ai envie de faire et puis
moi je ne pense pas l'histoire un acteur
parce que le texte je sais pas ce que
c'est je le perds la moitié du temps et
je travaille surtout un a essayé d'être
disponible à l'ecoute du fantasme du
metteur en scène
alors tant que j'ai eu la disponibilité
est là
et la force de le trouver ça allait mais
maintenant ça me donne de plus en plus
de mal et ça pose de plus en plus de
problèmes avec justement ma tribu alors
donc je vous mettre un frein
ça veut dire moins tourné moins tourné
puis essayer au lieu d'être le fantasme
la news j'ai envie de diriger mon
fantasme
enfin sans toi je n'ai vraiment une
histoire faisant un film dans lequel je
jouerai pas forcément en essayant de
travailler avec les gens qui me
ressemble
qui avec lesquels on peut s'écouter
votre femme était comédienne au départ
elle a fait un peu à l'affairé fait du
mime pour faire sa thèse
parce que ce qu'on veut et puis elle est
restée elle est à travailler avec
étienne decroux qui allait rester un peu
d'eux parce que ça lui plaisait à la
raison
et puis après bon elle s'est sacrifiée
parce que moi je vous ai fait deux
enfants qui étaient difficiles et elle a
préféré en avoir trois est-ce que moi
j'en étais un ici et maintenant que les
enfants sont grands que comprendre alors
on va essayer de travailler ensemble et
dans les histoires auxquelles vous
pensez il y avait un rôle quand votre
femme
je suis patient un rôle en tout cas il y
aura un rôle de scénariste d'auteur et
de créatrices certainement vous avez
déjà travaillé quelque chose ensemble
on essaye oui bien sûr l'appareil est
assez mais c'est déjà un drôle de
travail aussi